MALE SPEAKER:
AppCompat gives you
a consistent base
for your Android
app built on the principles
of material design.
But material design
is a lot more
than adding a toolbar
and some accent colors.
For everything else,
there's a design library.
The design library provides many
of the high-level components
you'll need to build
a great app that feels
at home with material design.
So what do you get?
A text input layout for adding
floating labels and errors
to edit text.
Floating action button
for the primary action
in your interface.
SnackBars for quick
feedback messages
with an optional action.
Material design compliant
tabs and navigation
view for building your
Navigation Drawer menu items.
Plus a lot of work, specifically
around motion and scrolling.
All this back through API7.
Text Input Layer wraps and edits
text, providing always visible
hint text, and a convenient
way of showing error
text via the set error method.
Floating Action Buttons are
ideal for that primary action
in your UI.
The design library's
Floating Action Button
sports both a default size
as well as a mini size,
useful for when the
Floating Action Button needs
to match with other elements.
Snackbars are a new way to
provide lightweight feedback
to your users.
Unlike toast messages, SnackBars
are an interactive part
of your UI, allowing you
to add an optional action
or allow the user to swipe
to dismiss the SnackBar.
This makes SnackBars very useful
around potentially destructive
operations.
A Click Undo Action can
save a lot of headache,
while providing a far better
experience than confirmation
dialogs.
Tabs have always been a
common pattern on Android,
both as top level
navigation for your app,
and for grouping
content within your app.
The design library's tab
layout supports fixed tabs
where each views width is split
equally between tabs, suitable
if you only have a
few important tabs,
as well supporting
scrollable tabs where you
have a large number of tabs.
We've made it easy to attach
your tab layout to a ViewPager,
keeping your tabs and
pages content in sync.
Just make sure your
pager adapter overrides
Get Page Title.
And then call Set
Up With ViewPager
to tie everything together.
An alternative to using tabs
as your top-level navigation
is the Navigation
Drawer-- a slide out
pane which offers navigation
between different parts
of your app.
Navigation View gives you
a perfectly styled drawer.
You just provide the
header, and then you
can add navigation
items programmatically
or via a Menu Resource File.
The simplest drawer menus will
have a group of checkable menu
items, using the
checkable behavior
equals single attribute.
This ensures that the checked
items will appear highlighted
in the Navigation View.
Support for subheaders using
subviews is also available.
That takes care of a lot of
the visuals of material design.
What about the motion
side of material design?
Coordinator motion is critical
to a great experience.
That's why the design library is
introducing CoordinatorLayout.
CoordinatorLayout
is a new layout
that allows children to
declare a behavior, giving them
extra controls
around touch events
and the ability to build
dependencies between views.
A great example of this is
when you use CoordinatorLayout
with the floating action button,
and then show a Snackbar.
The default behavior
for these components
allow the floating action
button to automatically move up
as the Snackbar animates
onto the screen,
ensuring that components
don't overlap,
without you writing
any code at all.
A major focus for
CoordinatorLayout
in this initial
release is around
enabling your appbar to react
to your main content scrolling.
By wrapping your toolbar
and other views, such as Tab
Layout, in an appbar
layout, you'll
gain access to the
special control flags,
allowing you to annotate each
component as something that
scrolls off the
screen, stays pinned
to the top of the screen,
or even returns immediately,
when you downward scroll, making
implementing a quick return
pattern just a few lines of XML.
No custom synchronized
scrolling code needed.
You can take things even further
by using a collapsing toolbar
layout.
This allows an
extended hide toolbar
to grow and shrink its title
text size as it collapses.
Pin elements to the top
of the collapsing toolbar,
parallax images, and even
add a full bleed scrim color
once it becomes collapsed.
Again, just a few lines of XML,
and that's all you'll need.
Getting started with the
design library is easy.
It's just a single
dependency to add.
With AppCompat as the base,
and the components provided
by the design
library on top of it,
there's no better time to get
started building great material
design apps.
We've only touched on the
features in the design library.
You're can learn even more about
the design library in the blog
post and on the developer site.
I'm looking forward to your
great material design apps.